[Musique]
que ce soit pour passer agréablement son
jeudi ou samedi
la rentrée scolaire va rapidement poser
aux parents le délicat problème de
l'argent de poche jetons téléphone pour
demander une recette de versions latines
150 francs pour aller au cinéma voir un
western qui vous font oublier l'amertume
d'une mauvaise note
les classiques distraction baby foot du
box flipper dont les parents redoutent
la séduction trop facile qu'elles sont
avec les cigarettes le jus de fruits les
disques et les gourmandises les dépenses
les plus fréquentes des lycéens cet
argent comment l'obtient ton facilement
ou difficilement régulièrement ou au
hasard de la bonne humeur familiale les
points de vue et les souhaits sont
différents selon qu'on donne ou qu'on
reçoit alors la glace est bonne vous
avez acheté comme ça plusieurs dans la
journée c'est surtout le nerf et des
biens pour l'exercice après l'exercice
vous avez une glace mais alors vous avez
droit à la glace ce jour au bon endroit
je dois passer un petit peu d'argent
pour koné vous avez un petit peu
d'argent on vous donne combien il n'y a
pas de prix fixe
ces dépenses soient s'est formé chez moi
à merde d'argent parce que d'abord en
bourbonnais mbida leurs filiales sonne
alors on lui dit maintenant j'ai plus
d'argent why on est toujours un peu
d'argent sur soi quoi avant très bien et
vous bon bah moi j'ai l'argent par
semaine - c'est 500 francs par semaine
vous avez cinq semaines qu'est ce que
vous achetez avec sa revanche j'ai
vraiment joué au cinéma théâtre ça
dépend des cinémas et théâtres mais sur
les cinq cent fois oui oui si mort si le
manque d'argent on demande plus tard de
vendée et vous vous avez combien
moi j'ai mis le faubourg semaine vous
avez migrants passés des rues et alors
qu'est ce que vous dépensez raté je les
fournitures scolaires enfin ce qu'il me
faut pour la semaine que des glaces
aussi de temps en temps des glaces de
tintin et bijoux originaux dans un vent
c'est dès 15h oui ça coûte hier vous
perdez beaucoup d'argent facile et ses
propos de 100 francs par semaine ces
enfants parrainés et vous achetez dd oui
mais enfin rarement d'autres sortir
des pois mais enfin je ne sais pas je
vois pas la foire du trône par exemple
vous avez quel âge aux 15 ans 15e ennuis
qu'ils aillent mais faisait combien
d'argent de poche
ce sont deux ou trois mille club des 3
me pour combien bon ça va c'est pas très
régulier des batailles qui passait pas
un salaire au bout de quoi des
compositions va bien réussi un comme ça
oui c'est pas un salaire régulier et
vous voici régulier ce que 500 francs
par mois ces enfants d'avoir vu quand
j'ai des compositions jour 5000 francs
conçu premier ou comme ça on va s'attend
j'attends pour noël on est vers 6 heures
comme ça oui
ouais c'est pareil je ne sais pas très
bien ces moments puisque comment le plus
le plus généreux même chance que la même
sur sa wii vraiment pas voir comme ça
j'arrête
ceux ci ont 16 et 17 ans ils sont élèves
de première et ont sérieusement penser
le problème de leur but et avez-vous 16
à 17 ans vous avez de l'argent de page
combien dans mois théoriquement dix
mille fois par mois ils feront par
semaine mieux les 7000 francs par mois
et cet argent de poche vous êtes
d'années comment par votre père ou par
votre mère c'est ma mère qui s'en
occupent mais c'est mon père qui nous
sommes par intermédiaire c'est maman qui
me le donne à votre thé ou par votre
mère à mère pourquoi par votre mère
parce que mon père est décédé
est ce qu'on vous demande des comptes
sur la façon dont vous le dépensent pas
du tout non plus mais bon je me laissais
faire un peu ce que je veux mais ils ne
sont pas très d'accord pour j'achète des
chose plus ou moins comment dirais je à
côté de ça côté quoi comme le disque par
exemple pendant sont plutôt anti twist
ça disparaît comme ça mais enfin je sais
pas je m'achète des photos pour mon
appareil photo
poisson j'ai un aquarium
et puis je suis pas les transports les
[Musique]
seins des dépenses courantes mais sur ce
il n'y a rien de particulier
aucun gros achats si je fais de
l'équitation alors je m'achète des
cartes de leçon évidemment personne pas
de scooter non non non je compte
m'acheter un solex mais pas plus en
faisant des économies
oh je pense que j'aurai assez d'argent
cet été mais non sans faire d'économie
bien marquer et vous commandez on veut
ça dépend les transports le cinéma
acheter des livres de temps en temps des
disques mais jamais de gros acheteurs
il y a d'abord mes transports et puis
mon coiffeur qui me revient assez cher
c'est 1000 francs normalement je devrais
y aller tous les mois mais j'y vais une
fois tous les deux mois pour économiser
un petit peu aussi j'ai aussi un temps
en temps j'aime beaucoup la musique qui
j'achète des disques
il ya aussi mes goûter à bosse fait mais
seulement maintenant je modère un petit
peu puisque depuis quelques temps ma
mère de ne me donne plus que 3000 francs
par mois 4000 francs par mois parce que
elle m'a prêté de l'argent pour acheter
une visionneuse animé en 8 mm alors ça
m'a prêté douze mille francs elle me
retiens trois mille francs par mois
il ya mon tabac alors point de vue tabac
je fais masser même trop pour mon âge ça
revient assez cher
il ya des disques j'aime bien la musique
enfin musique moderne
il ya des livres plus ou moins
intéressants et nous a poussés à peu
près tout
après tout à part quelques fois je vais
prendre un café quoi temps en temps et
tout ça sur les 4000 fois ou avec des
sublimes aubin temps en temps il ya des
suppléments quand on fait un appel
discret au peuple quoi ce que vous savez
tricher ou ruser pour faire cet appel
discret moi j'essaye de temps en temps
je me penche sur les spurs c'est à dire
que vous distille avec la somme que tu
as ça devrait suffire
c'est à peu près ce qu'ils me disent
chaque fois parce que c'est leur demande
assez souvent je suis toujours comme
munitions est ce que ça vous agace qu'on
vous refusez large aux non non ça ne
casse pas ça normal il n'y a aucune
folie à n'ont absolument aucune folie
temps en temps je vais au cinéma ce sont
ces petites dépenses autrement au point
de vue cigarette je ne fume eu pour
ainsi dire pas vous ne devez jamais aux
machines à sous
ah non ça jamais je suis même absolument
contre ce genre d'engin sa perverti la
jeunesse à ofer j'ai joué oui j'ai joué
pendant à peu près un mois et après j'ai
vu que l'argent filer trop vite alors
j'ai essayé de me passer tant que
finalement maintenant je ne joue pas
c'est trop cher ça fait des économies
c'est bien mieux comme ça est ce que
vous faites attention par exemple au
prix du café au prix du goûter oui mais
enfin je suis assez gourmand alors je
résiste pas tellement d'un bon chocolat
ou
un char le truc comme ça quoi est-ce que
vous avez l'impression de dépenser votre
argent ou l'argent de vos parents oh
bien sûr si l'argent de mes parents mais
enfin j'ai quand même l'impression que
c'est à moi une fois que mes parents me
l'ont donné cet argent est à moi oui
j'ai l'impression de dépenser mon argent
argent qui m'appartient moi aussi j'ai
l'impression de dépenser mon argent moi
c'est comme un peu si j'avais gagné ma
vie quoi est-ce que vous pensez que vos
parents font un siècle et 6,1 vous le
donnons aux bien sûr bien sûr
enfin je peux dire que c'est normal mais
quand même on a bien besoin d'argent de
poche
[Musique]